Coming from a place of being a serial
entrepreneur to this presidential
candidate is kind of warning people about
the upcoming technological apocalypse
as it were. Um, how did you
make that transition and what,
what was your motivation
to get involved in this?
To the point where we're actually
running for president on this platform?
Yeah. So, uh, so sell a company in 2009,
and that was the financial crisis.
Like Wall Street had crashed the economy
and I had personally taught these kids
who'd worked at Goldman Sachs and Morgan
Stanley and Mckinsey. And I was like,
man, we need smart kids to do something
other than just head to Wall Street and
Silicon Valley. We need to have them
go to Detroit, St Louis, Baltimore,
new and start businesses. So
I quit my job. I donated, um,
low six figures to start
this new organization.
And then we trained hundreds
of entrepreneurs and helped
create several thousand
jobs. So that was like my wholesome give
back. I was like, Hey, I'm like the,
you know, the guy who just believes in
entrepreneurship because just like you,
I freaking love entrepreneurs. And I was
like, so here's the joke. I used to tell,
I went to law school, I was an
unhappy lawyer for five months. Uh,
and so what I tell people is
like if you're a clueless,
ambitious 22 year old who came out of
college and you say to your parents, Hey,
I'm going to go to law school,
they're going to say, that's great.
It's really easy to find the law school.
Cause they're just,
they're just apply to it and the
government will give you $100,000 loan,
no questions asked. And then if
you say to your parents, Hey,
I want to be an entrepreneur,
your pants will think that's stupid.
It's hard to fly in and no one's
gonna give you $100,000 loan.
So we have this huge oversupply
of indebted law school graduates.
And the huge under supply of entrepreneurs
was my thinking. And so I was like,
okay, how do we fix that? So
I started this organization,
venture for America to try and fix that.
And so imagine being this guy,
getting medals and awards for helping
create jobs around the country.
And then realizing that automation's
coming like a tidal wave and that your
efforts that you're getting applauded
for are really not going to do the trick.
And then Donald Trump wins the election
in 2016 and for whatever reason,
in my opinion, the media is just not being
honest about all the economic drivers.
They're blaming racism, Russia, Facebook,
the FBI.
And if you look at the voter district
data on a district by district basis,
there's a straight line up between the
adoption of industrial robots in that
voting district and the
movement towards Trump. Mm.
Like it's a straight economic story
where we blasted away 4 million
manufacturing jobs in the swing states
and Donald Trump is our president.
So imagine being me and in seeing
that and being like, okay, I get it.
This is an economic,
technological story.
And then I went to people in
Washington DC. I was like, hey guys,
what are we going to do?
We're in the third inning of the
greatest economic and technological
transformation in the
history of our country.
And the third inning has brought
us Donald Trump. The fourth, fifth,
sixth things are going to be horrific.
What are we going to do?
And then the answers I got were somewhere
between disciplining and horrifying,
where if you go to mainstream
politicians and you're like,
what are we going to do? The answers
I got were literally number one,
we cannot talk about that.
Number two, we should study that.
We cannot talk about that was,
that's verbatim really. Yeah.
And why were they saying that?
Because it seems alarmists like
anti progress or like, you know,
you're like, uh, you know,
throwing stones at like,
like big tech companies and it's like,
I'm not throwing stones at anyone.
I'm just pointing out the
fact. So number one is, uh,
so number one was can't talk about it.
Number two was need to study it.
And the number three was the
point you made a originally,
which was we must educate and retrain
Americans for the jobs of the future.
And then when I was like, Hey, we're
terrible at that by the numbers,
then they'd literally be like,
well, I guess we'll learn
to get better at it then.
And then I, so I came back to, to my
home in New York City and I was like,
oh my gosh,
like we are so backward and far gone as a,
as it certainly as a government.
Um,
and so then I was grappling with
it and I'm a parent like you are.
And I looked at my kids and I was like,
am I really going to bring them up in
this shit show? Like, is this really,
is this really the plan? And
so then I was like, okay,
how would you actually solve this
problem if you, if you had to do so?
And so then I said, okay,
universal basic income,
rebranded the freedom dividend after we
did a bunch of tests because it tests
much better, um, as the freedom
dividend and universal basic income and,
and then, uh, try and make the,
the rules of the economy worked better
for more people as fast as we can before
this automation wave really crescendos.
What do you mean by that? Well to me,
like,
you know what I'm saying is like retail
and truck driving are the two major,
major, obvious sectors that
are going to get displaced.
Being a retail worker is the most common
job in the United States right now.
The average retail workers,
a 39 year old woman with a high school
education making between 11 and $12 an
hour.
So what do those workers do in 30% of
the malls and stores close in the next
five years? You know, and then
truckers are next in line, you know,
by the five to 10 year mark.
So I was like,
we have to get our acts together
before these populations end up getting
displaced. And we know Americans don't
have a ton of savings to fall back on.
It's not like they'll be
like, oh, like, you know,
let me take a month off to like
think about like, that's not,
that's not the real life
situation. Most Americans, uh,
live and experience.
So,
so this is all 2017 where I'm like doing
the data research and saying like, okay,
like what's the plan? And then when I
went to various politicians, I was like,
there is no appetite for making this case.
There's no appetite for anyone
even talking about this.
So the only thing I can see that would
have a realistic chance of accelerating
meaningful solutions to this automation
wave in a five to 10 year timeframe is
if I run for president and I either
win, which is very doable, I can win,
um,
or I mainstream this set of considerations
to a point where other politicians
are willing to tackle something like
universal basic income and make it a
reality in that timeframe.